bom dia pessoal sim de 15 minutos eu
tivesse 15 segundos para deixar uma
mensagem para vocês
acho que a mensagem seria que existe
muita coisa boa acontecendo em educação
no brasil
o senso comum é que a educação
brasileira principalmente a pública' vai
de mal a pior melhor
será tudo destruir construir tudo de
novo e não principalmente esse ano eu
encontrei muita coisa legal
muitos projetos incríveis e muita gente
com vontade de fazer pra valer de mudar
isso e mudar essa imagem mostrar que a
educação no brasil é muito boa mesmo
eu sou formado em jornalismo mas eu
brinca não sou jornalista sempre
trabalhei em educação mas eu sempre
trabalhei a maioria das vezes a educação
dentro do escritório tinha muito pouco o
pé no chão da escola chegou uma época da
minha vida
no final do ano passado que eu não via
mais sentido em construir produzir
conteúdos produtos e serviços para o
brasil inteiro
será que eu não ia para a escola e não
vinha acontecendo não conversava com as
pessoas que usavam as coisas que
produzia vivia mudando a vida de ninguém
e então antes de criar o carro no brasil
o tema mala - uma mochila nas costas e
fui viajar
eu fui pra 58 cidades que eu queria ver
era conhecido eu queria conhecer as
realidades brasileiras mais do que
educação paulo freire mesmo sempre disse
que é importante conhecer as realidades
então chegar na cidade
andar pela cidade está aberto para ouvir
as pessoas e buscava conhecer práticas
que realmente fossem diferentes que
trouxessem soluções criativas para os
desafios que a gente tem hoje
o histórias de pessoas que ensinassem
coisas novas para a gente em educação
coisa que a gente muitas vezes não
lembra
no total foram cinco meses comecei em
belém e foi descendo até são paulo tudo
de ônibus trem barco foram 17 mil
quilômetros
dias dentro de algum meio de transporte
mas mais legal quando as histórias e as
práticas que eu vi no caminho e saiu de
são paulo com uma lista de 30 escolas
práticas histórias de pessoas pra
conhecer e chegando no lugar chegando
nas cidades
parece uma coisa que hoje parece óbvia
mas na época não era quem mora em são
paulo não conhece a prática que pode ser
mais interessante em jericoacoara
lá no norte do ceará que mora em
jericoacoara assim conhece essa pessoa
essa prática com essa história de
pessoas
então comecei a conversar com o dono do
rosto eu pra moça do museu com garçom no
restaurante e contasse uma história que
eu queria conhecer as realidades e
queria conhecer práticas que realmente
fossem diferentes
uma escola tradicional aqui tem um monte
é preciso em são paulo no meu bairro tem
várias escolas falta banheiro também não
estava e até palmas pra encontrar uma
escola falta banheiro e nem precisa
ficar sabendo disso também porque jataí
na mídia a rodo e com isso eu tirei duas
conclusões principais a primeira é que
todas essas 30 práticas que eu conheci
que a maioria eram locais ou regionais
coisas que muitas vezes brasil não
conhece
quero muito mais interessante do que as
práticas estão no meu papel são ligadas
por uma coisa que a gente tá cada vez
mais popular chamado de educação vivo de
uma educação de forma pro cidade forma o
mercado de trabalho
hoje em dia a sociedade exige de um cara
que sabe trabalhar em grupo saiba falar
só de um lugar saudável outro autônomo
responsável muitas vezes a escola não
consegue preparar e entregar esse cara
para a sociedade muito menos para o
mercado de trabalho e é um grande
problema
um dia me deram uma tarefa pra eu fazer
eu fiz eu fui mostrar a minha chefe só
pra ver se dava certo eu vou ou não eu
te dou economia pra isso e eu me
desesperei porque nunca tinha guiado
autonomia pra nada para entregar direto
com o cliente
outra coisa que eu vi que eu constatei a
educação
um acontece em qualquer lugar à educação
acontece numa casinha que a gente
costuma chamar de escola educação
acontece embaixo de um pé de manga como
disse disso tinham rocha e paulo freire
aprendeu inglês prevê no quintal dele
então eu pude ver isso e viver isso de
perto
conhecendo essas práticas eu ia como
jornalista nas escolas e ouvia o que os
diretores o que os gestores tinham pra
falar sobre aquela prática e tentava
sempre conversar com os outros autores
envolvidos e ver a prática acontecendo
mesmo se não pudesse conversar com as
outras pessoas muitas vezes nos alunos
estavam ocupados não estava na escola
mas eu sempre dá um jeito de andar com a
escola
senti um pouco como funciona aqui um dia
a dia e e aqui eu vou trazer breves
cases para mostrar que esses valores da
educação viva podem ser aplicados em
várias escolas são presos de uma escola
e pela alternativa para isso existe
escola tradicional que aplica a esses
valores muito bem e de vez em quando de
maneira muito simples
a primeira escola que eu vou falar fica
em brasília chama vivendo e aprendendo o
que é incrível de diálogo democracia o
diálogo porque a associação então pais
professores e alunos de uma escola de
educação infantil constrói a escola
junto no diálogo sempre isso não
existiria se não fosse essa conversa mas
que isso quando estava conversando com a
coordenadora e falou olha aqui a gente
ensina não gosto como assim você não
gosta é geralmente quando você faz
alguma coisa que outra pessoa não gosta
a gente adulta não sabe lidar muito bem
com isso não há gente para de falar a
gente bate uma pessoa a gente mata a
pessoa datena existe por isso escrevi
aqui as crianças aprendem a falar não
gosto e eu já estava há alguns meses na
estrada e falar isso aí é um só querem
impressionar e não quando estava andando
pela escola
eu tinha ajudaria na cara de um moleque
e daí o professor que estava junto com
esse 12 anos
eles não sabiam falar muito bem o
professor foi maria não jogarei na cara
do joão que já não gosta disso
na hora ela parou é o modo de ser
daquela escola que faz o aluno aprenderá
de alugar e aprendeu a olhar o outro
agente maria não vai fechar o meu carro
no meio do trânsito da cidade
outra coisa muito legal dessa escola que
acontece em outras também que os
próprios alunos aprendem a debater e
criar suas regras de convivência e viver
num coletivo de uma maneira saudável de
verdade é essa por exemplo foi feito por
alunos de três anos não pode cuspir nem
modelo em buscar porque surge dói é uma
regra pra vida né
pense nisso e mais do que isso a vivendo
e aprendendo que essa escola de brasília
mostrou pra mim é a diversão é realmente
uma peça fundamental na educação afirmou
outra escola um dia ea diretora mostrou
orgulhosa uma fila para cantina ou não
porque aqui a gente tem esse nível de
excelência porque a gente tem disciplina
em que preza pela disciplina
olhando aquilo mas será que uma fila
praticamente militar com uma disciplina
mega rígida é o melhor jeito de fazer e
quando ouvia vivendo em uma hora de
parque na hora de recreio uma hora
durante o dia 10 quando park brincando
com pessoas de outra com jovens
rapazinhos que uns de outras cidades
nesse momento muito feliz mais aprendem
ensino uns para os outros não importa
que você tem dois anos pode ensinar o
garoto que tem seis
o nome dele não sabe o que faz se não
sabe o que ele gosta as habilidades e
competências e essa escola em brasília
também faz isso
os preços são sensíveis para olhar para
cada aluno chegou a garotinha diretora
me contou que chegou um garoto de 9 anos
que não sabem ler nem escrever
depois de passar por vários métodos de
ensino
ea professora perguntou acho que é a
primeira vez que ele me perguntou para
ele isso que ele queria ser quando
crescesse
ele falou que era elegante elegante como
dançarinos de tango
se não foi a primeira vez que ele por
perguntado sobre o que queria ser quando
crescesse
foi a primeira vez que ouviu e levou em
conta isso
a professora usou o tango como tema
geradora da alfabetização 12 meses ele
estava alfabetizada
de acordo com o que me contaram ainda
não conheço ele
vou para brasília em novembro quero
muito conhecê lo porque hoje ele é um
advogado
eu brinco que o advogado tem um elegante
com dançarinos de tango e obriga também
é bom de medo de seu advogado porta de
cadeia é nada elegante
outra coisa é muito importante em suas
unidades
esse projeto também brasília chama
revivendo exibidos durante um ano eles
estudam uma região com base na
identidade meio ambiente patrimônio da
região
estudantes do ensino médio e no fim do
ano eles com 15 dias andando por essa
região e vendo que eles aprenderam na
prática eles saem da escola e fazem uma
caminhada de 15 quilômetros por dia pra
olhar o que eles aprenderam conversar
com as comunidades devem se unir a eles
lhes ensinam nas comunidades saem
totalmente diferente do jeito que eles
entraram até pra você ver sua própria
realidade não o que acontece no seu
bairro
você pode ser um agente de transformação
no seu bairro na sua cidade no seu país
de tudo isso eu tirei duas conclusões
primeira que realmente você pode
aprender em qualquer lugar pode aprender
na escola na casinha pode aprender na
embaixo da árvore pode aprender aqui e
outra conclusão o mega importante
um dia estava no ônibus indo pra são
joão del rei em minas gerais chegou um
senhor e começou a conversar comigo e eu
tava na vibe da viagem é só conversar
com todo mundo e se a pessoa vem falar
comigo melhor ainda
igor contou que nunca pisou numa sala de
aula porque a escola ficava duas horas
de distância a pé da casa dele e na
época ele tem 1 60 anos na época não
tinha ônibus e ele era pobre não
conseguiu ir à escola
luiz foi um grande professor pra mim
talvez um dos principais da viagem
porque primeiro a filha dele
hoje faz engenharia então um cara que
não estudou conseguiu transformar a vida
dele conseguiu dar possibilidades para a
filha dele não ter a mesma possibilidade
de frequentar a escola que teve mais do
que isso o são luiz
eu fiquei uma hora conversando com ele e
todo final de frase que ele falava era
mas isso você deve saber por que você
estudou deve saber por que você fez
faculdade e não eu fiquei empresa não
saber nada do que os egoísmos contava
que era a realidade dele eram saberes
dele não sabia nem que eu não sei quanto
um hectare e ele sabe olhar o hectare
por olho
isso pra mim na cidade não pode ser pode
não ser importante mas para ele é
fundamental e isso me ensinou que é isso
você pode é todo mundo é educadora
educação acontece natural
a primeira palestra falou sobre qual o
freire foi uma frase uma fala do paulo
freire que é os homens educam entre si
mediatizados pelo mundo
também eu queria deixar com vocês essa
provocação de que vocês podem ensinar e
aprender em qualquer lugar
e vocês podem pegar e compartilhar seus
conhecimentos e fazer coisas concretas
realmente mudem as suas vidas mudam a
vida dos outros e mudem a realidade
presente essa imagem da educação
brasileira que muitas vezes não é tão
boa
existem sim ótimas pessoas trabalhando
existem sim projetos fantásticos que tem
que ser com mais compartilhados
essas soluções têm que ser olhados e
aplicadas em outros projetos inspirar
pessoas para essa revolução acontecer
vocês podem fazer isso aqui agora olhar
para o lado
não tá e aí quem você que você sabe
fazer né que você pode me ensinar o que
eu posso ensinar o que a gente pode
fazer junto e eu acho que essa é a
mensagem que eu queria deixar ainda bem
que não tive só a 15 segundos
obrigado pessoal